[Music]  why did you make me do that look at me  focus on my voice I'm not giving up on  you Jean she was my friend you're my  family James no matter what  look your special gene  and if you start fighting that force  inside you  Phil Grayson he will possess the very  power of a god oculus all tell me how we  fix this trough tell me what to do I  don't know what to do  what they don't understand  they fear and what they fear we say to  destroy  sure all Charles tries to protect our  I'm scared  when I lose control bad things happen to  people i watch the girl dies she's still  June we can still help her sometimes he  want to believe people as something that  they are not  by the time he knows who they are  it's too late  she's coming  [Music]  [Music]